mir geht super dir auch mir auch alles
gut bin bisschen durch aber trotzdem
guter Dinge und immer die Kamera im
Anschlag nicht immer aber immer öfter do
ich habe ein paar Sachen gefilmt pa
interessante lustige
Sachen kanst gleich super ja das ist gut
bin
gespannt auch kölche jung ne ich bin
auch kölung ich komme aber nicht aus
Neubrück ich komme aus dbrück ich komme
auch nicht aus Neubrück aber ne
überhaupt nie ist ein Märchen ich bin
ein Skateboard gefahren ach so sondern
wo hast meine Eltern wohnen in Brück so
ich komme aus der Südstadt aus der
Südstadt da bist du noch ein richtiger
Co als ich gut wir sind hier im wie ist
die Lage die Lage ist ähm die Lage ist
gut ja also ich bin gerade mitten in der
Promotion komme gerade aus Berlin und
freue mich mit dir zu sprechen
m und bin aber auch gleich schon wieder
auf dem Sprung nach Paris die die Lage
ist
ja sehr beschäftigt die Lage ist
beschäftigt ich bin in der Beschäftigten
Lage in Beschäftigten Lage m als Musiker
ist das dann angenehm oder ist das eher
unangenehm also ich glaube unangenehm
wäre wenn keiner mit dir ein Interview
machen würde so ja also es ist für dich
keine mühselige Pflicht wie bei sido z.B
dem tut das der kriegt davon
Magenkrämpfe also ach ich glaube beim
sido ist das genauso irgendwie wenn
keiner mit ihm Interview machen würde
dann
würd es zu schätzen wissen wobei es gibt
eine lustige Geschichte habe ich gerade
mit Kollegen drüber gesprochen der
wollte ein Interview mit
raikuda machen und raikuder verlangte ja
gerne aber du musst vorher mein
Gesamtwerk
kennen kann ich zum Teil verstehen also
ich habe ja meinen mein neues Album
heißt der diversity und es gibt da
diesen watermark Schutz ich weiß nicht
ob du davon gehört hast auf der CD auf
der CD damit irgendwie falls in
Journalist dann die CD ins Netz setzt
kann man zurückverfolgen wer das war und
dann kam halt ein Journalist l der dann
gesagt hat ja deine mit sächsischen
Akzent noch deine neue CD heißt ja
watermark erzähl doch mal und das ist
dann so ein bisschen okay du hast weder
reingehört noch so da gibt's halt nicht
wirklich eine Basis also ich finde schon
gut wenn der Journalist der mich
interviewt sich so ein bisschen vorher
vorbereitet hat wobei du gibst ja auch
den Kollegen super Chance sich
vorzubereiten wir waren bei einem
preistening für jemand der das nicht
kennt du lädst Kollegen ein und da wird
deine CD vorgespielt und du erzählst
jedes mal was davor was ein natürlich
super Einblick in das Album bekommt weil
man erfährt auch wie das Stück
entstanden ist wie du du hast sehr viele
collaborations jetzt in dem Album mit
zahlreichen Künstlern wie es dazu
gekommen ist ist das üblich in der
Branche dass man das macht oder ist das
so ein Zeichen von dir ich gebe mir da
besondere Mühe damit mir das B nicht
passiert dass keiner mein Album vorher
gehört hat vor ein Interview ich weiß
nicht ob das üblich ist ich bin jetzt
auch nicht so ich weiß jetzt nicht so
Bescheid wie das bei anderen Künstlern
ist so
ich habe das in der Form aber auch noch
nie gehabt also es gab mal irgendwie
auch vom be bei journey to J oder bei
confidence bei dem Album gab's auch mal
eine listening Session aber
m das war viel kürzer und nicht so
persönlich nicht so intim ich habe auch
nicht so viel dazu erzählt ich glaube
dieses Format
ist ist relativ neu ob das jetzt andere
Künstler machen weiß ich nicht ich bin
angefragt worden von der Plattenfirma
kannst jetzt vor Stellen zu machen und
ich fand das cool ja weil einfach die
Leute irgendwie einblück kriegen und
dann dementsprechend auch drüber
schreiben und ist einfach was
persönliches ist hat es sich so positiv
ausgewirkt also bist du mit der
Berichterstattung jetzt schon
zufriedener ich habe noch nicht so viel
gelesen irgendwie das das zeigt sich
jetzt alles irgendwie aber das Feedback
von den Journalisten wenn sie mich nicht
angelogen haben war dann doch ganz gut
war eher positiv als negativ war eine
super listening Session irgendwie ich mE
es gab ja auch ein reichliches Buffet
und so weiß du also ich würd mich als
Journalist
wohlfühlen aber passiert ja nicht dass
du auch angelogen wirst dass die sagen
super Album und dann siehst Du
irgendwann den Artikel und denkst Moment
mit wem habe ich da geredet eigentlich
ich hat schon ganz schlimme Erfahrung
ich habe irgendwie z.B irgendwie mit
Journalisten namens Ingo von der Neon ja
voll die schmierwurst das ist das ist
die zeitsch wo die gefälschten
Interviews drin waren ja ich finde ja
die Neon gut es ging halt nur um diesen
Ingo ich weiß gar nicht mehr kleinhammer
oder aber Ingo hieß der ja schreibt auch
immer noch für die Neon so und ist echt
eine schmierwurst so das ist nämlich ein
Typ der dir ins Gesicht grinst und sagt
so wow so hey super wir haben ihn nach
Jamaica eingeladen so ja vor music hat
ih nach Jamaica eingeladen
m und ich habe ihn nicht mit in die
ghettto Studios genommen sondern wir
haben in M Resort irgendwie ein
Interview gemacht und ich hatte das
Gefühl es war ein super Gespräch und er
sagt mir nach ein Gespräch hey super
Interview und ist echt toll sowas habe
ich noch nie gehabt und danke irgendwie
auch für die Reise und so und ähm und
hat ein Artikel geschrieben der war so
unter der Gürtellinie s hatten halt alle
Mücken Stiche und dann waren dann so
Sätze wie und jetzt kratzt der Otto sich
am
Allerwertesten und ähm so eine
scheinheilige Musik und und nur so
irgendwie wo ich das Ding gelesen habe
und gedacht so okay das gibt's natürlich
auch so das immer die Gefahr auch wenn
man Journalisten nah an sich ranlässt
irgendwie aber das war dann das war eher
die Ausnahme also ich habe eigentlich so
durchweg gute Erfahrung mit
ournalismemach und ich bin halt jemand
der auch Leuten immer mit Respekt
gegenüber tret irgendwie und fahr glaube
ich ganz gut damit irgendwie ja also ich
habe wie gesagt
irgendwie die meisten Artikel die ich
über mich gelesen habe irgendwie mit
denen konnte ich auf jeden Fall Leben du
sagtest gerade scheinheilige Musik
regy hat regy noch stark mit Vorurteilen
zu kämpfen oder ich sag mal mit
Vorbehalten ja immer wieder ich glaube
das Problem an der Musik ist dass sie
gerade irgendwie in unserem breiten
geraden immer so missverstanden wird ja
also früher in das extrem und heute in
das andere
Extrem früher war es so die die reggy
Sunshine Feeling Mucke so alle laufen
barfuß rum und kiffen sich die BNE weg
und haben die rosarote Brille auf
und und alles ist peace und love und
happiness und Bob Mali hat damals schon
gesungen i shut the sheriff so ist das
peaceful und so ja also da war ja schon
immer Missverständnis ich weiß nicht ob
das an laidback lag irgendwie mit ihrem
Song Sunshine regy warum die Musik die
ja unfassbar sozialritisch politisch
rebellisch ist so so ein Image hat
irgendwie we jetzt in Jamaica immer die
Sonne scheint aber
Jamaica ist alles andere als Sunshine
Feeling
so und jetzt hat die Musik damit zu
kämpfen dass es irgendwie Hassprediger
Musik geworden ist so wie es die Welt
mal oder die die Tatz mal geschrieben
hat weil ja viele Künstler eine Meinung
vertreten die wir oder die ich nicht
vertrete was was die Homophobie in der
Musik angeht die genauso im hiphhop
vertreten ist
in der katholischen Kirche ja in der
Bibel der Papst sagt das gleiche wie in
sisler nur nicht ganz so radikal und
ja wobei da geht's ja darum dass
wirklich sag mal Homosexuellen der Tod
gewünscht wird
was aber wo glaube ich auch mit den
jikanischen Gepflogenheiten zu ja aber
da ist ja genau die Gefahr so also ich
meine ganz klar distanziere mich von
solchen Lyrics und ich kann nicht
verstehen wie man jemand aufgrund seiner
Sexualität diskriminieren kann so und
trotzdem muss man einfach mal sehen
irgendwie da ähm da wird eine
Symbolsprache verwendet ja das ist
irgendwie das sind Metaphern dieses
fireburn das ist ja so ein typischer
Ausdruck irgendwie der regy immer wieder
stattfindet wovon Bob Marley auch schon
gesungen hat oder man to man ist so
unchust hat Bob Marley auch gesungen so
müss man ihn eigentlich auch auf den
Index jetzt stellen so ähm aber die
Diskussion ist so dermaßen aus um Ruder
gelaufen ja dass ich mich irgendwie
mittlerweile Frage irgendwie so hey wo
sollen das noch hingehen ähm
wenn sogenannte Aktivisten irgendwie
unter dem Deckmantel Political
Correctness buttersäureanschläge verüben
auf auf reggy Konzerte wie es in Berlin
der Fall war oder in Zürich oder
oder auch in in Wien dann ich habe noch
nie erlebt dass nach dem Konzert die
Besucher irgendwie jetzt mit Benzin auf
die Straße rennen und H sexuelle
anzünden die Übergriffe sind auch in in
Russland
viel mehr als in Jamaika obwohl es in
Russland nicht unbedingt regy gibt so ja
also da äh wenn man versucht mit so
einem gefährlichen Halbwissen Text eins
zu eins ins Deutsche zu übersetzen dann
wird's einfach schwierig und wenn Volker
Beck irgendwie von den Grünen aus der
Opposition es durchsetzen kann dass ganz
viele regy Künstler einfach irgendwie
keine Einreise Erlaubnis mehr kriegen
praktisch auf die gleiche Stufe gestellt
werden wie talibankämpfer so wenn regy
Platten die nicht homophob sind auch auf
dem Index landen ja weil sie falsch
verstanden würden neben rechtsradikalen
Platten
dann frage ich mich irgendwas stimmt da
nicht so ich appelliere dann so an beide
Seiten mal so ein bisschen
runterzukommen und einfach zu sehen hey
ich kann nicht nach vatian City gehen
und da Kondomautomaten aufstellen ich
kann nicht in Iran gehen und sagen ey
warum tragt ihr denn ja alle Kopftücher
und ich kann auch nicht nach Jamaica
gehen und sagen wie könnt ihr denn bloß
gegen Homosexualität sein ja also wenn
zisler mir sagt irgendwie hey ich kann
das als rastermann mit meinem Glauben
nicht vereinbaren so dann kann ich das
akzeptieren obwohl ich es nicht
nachvollziehen kann ja und da fehlt mir
so ein bisschen irgendwie die
Sensibilität auch und
ähm ich halte mich halt so ein bisschen
an den oder ich halte mich und das ist
das was was mir Hoffnung gibt irgendwie
an den Gemeinsamkeiten fest und kann die
Differenzen akzeptieren und das ist so
ein Ding was ich irgendwie von Rasta
auch gelernt habe so ein bisschen dieses
ähm selbstständige Denken ja so dieses
Ding irgendwie Sachen mal auch zu
hinterfragen was in unseren
Geschichtsbüchern uns da so verklickert
wird so wo ich dann auch in der Schule
immer ges so wie cololumbus das war doch
voll der Arsch so warum feiert ihr den
denn hier als Helden so der geht dahin
und metzelt die Leute nieder und und so
weiter und so for irgendwie oder wenn
ich dann auch mir so die Bücher von
meinem Sohn im man angucke was dann
irgendwie teilweise so auch in Religion
und
so ja ich will da jetzt nicht so der
super Rebel sein und alles irgendwie
durcheinander bringen so aber ich finde
einfach auch wichtig Sachen zu
hinterfragen und selbständig zu denken
so und vor allen Dingen auch Sachen mal
zu überprüfen so zu sagen moment mal
kann ich das mit mir vereinbaren so und
nicht immer alles direkt anzunehmen und
da ist Raster ganz weit vorne so du
sagst du wiist auf dem Weg zur Wahrheit
wie nah glaubst du bist du dran a ich
weiß es nicht manchmal das Gefühl ich
bin ganz weit weg und dann gibt's
Momente da bin ich ich weiß nicht ob man
das so als Weg bezeichnen kann so aber
ich glaube jeder sucht irgendwo nach der
Wahrheit oder oder so jeder ist irgendwo
auf der Suche und selbst wenn er denkt
er wä es nicht dann ist er es irgendwo
oder wird dann wahrscheinlich irgendwann
anfangen so also ich glaube es geh das
immer so phasenweise so ich habe
manchmal manchmal lebe ich ein
oberflächliches Leben und das tut dann
auch mal ganz gut irgendwie so und
ähm guck mir irgendwelche scheißsender
an und Spiel Playstation und so und
trink Bier irgendwie und manchmal
habe ich das Gefühl ich brauche jetzt
wieder ein bisschen geistige Nahrung
irgendwie und und und hab ein ganz
anderes Bewusstsein und versuch dann
auch mich anders zu ernähren irgendwie
aber ich glaube es geht schon in die
Richtung so
ähm dass das mehr wird so hoffe ich mal
was meinst du was die Wahrheit ist
meinst du dass sich etwas ganz konkretes
wirklich tut eine erkenntnisbreit Macht
sag mal bei Douglas Adams wird das ja
auf die wird's ja verarscht dann wird
gesagt 42 ist die Lösung aller
Fragen aber es könnte ja sein dass wir
was ich glaube ich habe es auch bei dir
in irgendeinem Text gelesen das ist was
ganz konkretes ist etwas wo wir denken
ja warum haben wir das nicht gesehen ich
glaube ich weiß es ja nicht so aber vom
Gefühl her so oder was ich zumindest ist
was glaube ich was ganz einfaches so und
vielleicht gibt's ja so eine kollektive
Wahrheit so aber ich habe keine Ahnung
so also hattest du jetzt schon mal
Erlebnisse wo du sagtest da ist mir was
passiert das muss damit zu tun ja klar
man es gibt immer irgendwelche Momente
wo man das Gefühl hat so wow was war das
denn jetzt ich meine das sind so so
Sachen wie keine Ahnung
das das Telefon klingelt irgendwie und
du hast auf einmal das Gefühl ey das ist
pramada so der der Typ den ich irgendwie
vor 5 Jahren in Indien das letzte Mal
gesehen habe eine Sekunde vor und dann
ist er das so das hatte ich mal so ja
und du denkst nur so alter Schwede das
gibt's doch nicht so ja oder irgendwie
du gehst mit jemanden irgendwie über die
Straße und redest eine halbe Stunde
nicht und fängst genau in dem gleichen
Sekunden an irgendwie einen Song zu
singen so ja oder
Musik allgemein irgendwie oder so diese
Emotionen die ja irgendwie
kulturübergreifend sind so ja dass
wirklich alle Menschen die gleichen
Emotionen haben egal was was es für eine
Religion jetzt ist oder wo sie herkommen
oder Konditionierung haben so ähm ich
glaube es gibt eine kollektive Wahrheit
und dann gibt's irgendwie eine einzelne
Wahrheit um zu der kollektiven Wahrheit
zu
kommen ja könnte
sein die Frage ist ja ist Musik dann was
göttliches und ist mit sogar mit regy
besonders da dran ja ich meine wenn
jemand auf Rock steht ist Rock auch
göttlich so ja oder sogar Techno kann
für jemanden wahrscheinlich göttlich
sein für mich jetzt nicht so aber na
klar also Musik ist irgendwie ich glaube
alles das was wenn man wirklich mal so
im Moment ist so das ist so wenn man
wirklich mal den Moment auch erlaubt so
ja und nicht immer
diese diese Wünsche hat irgendwas für
die Zukunft oder irgend oder ja oder
Ängste hat so weil die Ängste hängen ja
auch immer irgendwie mit der Zukunft
zusammen ist ja eigentlich nie die
Situation glaube ich so ist immer eher
so das Beurteilen von der Situation was
einem irgendwie Angst macht oder was so
Panikattacken auch auslösen kann so oder
ich weiß nicht früher auch in Interviews
ich hat auch ganz oft so Bo und was geht
denn jetzt ab und bin auf einmal
tierisch so bin bin hab gedacht was geht
denn hier was ist denn hier los und das
aber dann irgendwann habe ich gemerkt D
das ist nur so eine Beurteilung der
Situation die Situation ist völlig okay
so und das ist immer dieses Ding so wenn
man Angst vor der Zukunft hat oder eben
das Gefühl so ach war das damals schön
oder was auch immer ich glaube wir
vergessen oft so oder ich auch so im
Moment zu sein irgendwie und das ist das
was Musik macht so in dem Moment wo ich
Musik mache oder wir spielen Konzert so
und ich wir sind auf der Bühne und da
sind Leute und die haben alles smiling
faces so und und tanzen dazu so dann ist
das sowas unglaublich momentanes so und
und mehr braucht man ja gar nicht so ja
so der Moment ist ja schon eigentlich
ein volles Geschenk so ja und ich glaube
das ist so ähm wahrhaftig so ein Moment
so es gibt ja nur zwei Dinge die direkt
ins Hirn gehen das ist Sex und Musik ja
das ist GI nur alles andere ist halt
immer vermittelt über alles andere denkt
man nach man überlegt gehe ich über die
Straße ma ich es nicht okay alles und
ist es vielleicht ist es das bei Musik
das ist dieses man muss sich einlassen
ja können nehme ich mal an wen ich kann
nicht komponieren aber ich nehme mal an
man muss sich ja irgendwie in eine
Situation bringen ich habe das mit hermo
zeret mal den du auch gut kennst
diskutiert er meinte auch ich kann nicht
sagen woher das kommt plötzlich ist das
da plötzlich ist das da ja wenn man es
erklären könnte dann wä es ja auch gar
nicht kein Mysterium mehr irgendwie also
ich finde es auch gerade mit anderen
Musikern zu arbeiten oder gerade auch in
in Studios in Jamaica zu sein irgendwier
im Proberaum zu sein wenn wenn alle
irgendwas suchen so h man hört sowas und
irgendwie irgendwas fehlt noch so und
dann ist es auf einmal so klar und alle
denken so na klar so ja man kann es eben
nicht erklären oder auch irgendwie eine
Melodie wie eine Melodie so kommt ja ich
hör dann irgendwie ein Instrumental so
und dann ist ist ja irgendwie also ich
habe das Gefühl man muss ich halt
irgendwie öffnen so und dann wie der
Fußballer so schön sagt das dann einfach
nur abrufen so und dann ist im Raum auf
einmal die Melodie und dann
so dann hat man die Melodie auf einmal
so und dann spürt man das so oder man
spürt es eben nicht so ist abgefahren
das neue Album kommt mit 19 trcks glaube
ich aber nicht nur es gibt eine Delux
Version mit 28 Tracks und es gibt eine
venyl singlebx
ich glaube auch mit allen 28 drecks
drauf das heißt es sind 14 14 Singles
Hammer super oder und was ich gehört
habe alles super ich find es auch ich
bin auch echt zufrieden ich habe es
jetzt wie gesagt noch nicht so oft
gehört so aber ich habe mir echt Mühe
gegeben habe auch ja mir Zeit genommen
den ersten Song habe ich vor zwei Jahren
aufgenommen changes und ich glaube ich
habe mittlerweile gelernt oder ich lerne
gerade diese diese Momente weil es sind
immer nur Momente irgendwie so ist es
zumindest bei mir ich kann nicht
irgendwie bin nicht permanent in diesem
in dieser Kreativität so oder in dieser
Hochphasen und wenn man aber so ein
Moment hat irgendwie dass man den auf
jeden Fall zu schätzen wissen muss und
dann auch wirklich so jetzt packe ich
ihn an so und jetzt mache ich was Drau
und nicht irgendwie ich habe eine gute
Idee aber die ist bestimmt morgen auch
noch da so wei ist wirklich dieser
Moment irgendwie und da kam sicher dazu
dass ich eben jetzt auch mein eigenes
Studio in Köln bei mir zu Hause fertig
gestellt habe und eben auch nachts mal
um 4 Uhr aufgestanden bin auf einmal und
hatte wirklich so voll Bock und drang
jetzt Mucke zu machen so und bin dann
runter ins Studio gegangen und ich weiß
genau es ruft keiner an um 4 Uhr
schlafen alle 4 Uhr ist eh eine
Superzeit für Kreativität so ist der
Hammer muss mal ausprobieren we sofort
na ja so weckerstellen auf 4 Uhr und
dann irgendwas schreiben oder so ist
super und dann kam halt eben ganz viele
Ideen und diese Momente sind halt
wertvoll und die muss man dann nutzen da
muss man auch alles andere abschotten
irgendwie weil es gibt dann auf jeden
Fall wieder die F irgendwie wo dann auch
nichts ist so das ist kein kreatives
Brett da an sowas glaube ich nicht weil
man kann sich immer ausdrücken irgendwie
aber es gibt halt dieses speziellen
Moment es gibt Berge und Täler und ohne
die Täler gibt's die Berge nicht oh
super das ist ein songwert in diesem
Sinne herzlich willkommen auf dem Mount
Everest ja cool vielen
Dank